[Music]
david is in albuquerque hi david welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so my fiance and i we've both been
blessed uh
parents that espouse the same principles
that you teach every day
um both of our parents grew up because
my dad would say
uh didn't make enough money to be poor
and so when we grew up
we grew up very frugal so now that my
fiance and i
have graduated college and don't have
any student loans or anything like that
we know what works but emotionally we
sort of have this itch to get some of
the things that
some of the finer things that we didn't
have growing up
so we know what to do mentally
but our our emotions are kind of you
know bringing us to the mercedes-benz
website
and looking at brand new cars so what's
your advice as far as
getting uh ourselves to motivate each
other to
stay focused on that same path that our
parents were on
how old are you guys uh i'm 30 and my
fiance is 25.
when you're getting married september
18th
congratulations that's wonderful thank
you
well um the bible says where there is no
vision
the people perish would you agree with
me that spending money that you don't
have and get yourself deeply in debt so
that you're broke
would be a dumb idea
absolutely okay so to have a vision to
not do that
would be a smart idea so we need a
vision for
how we want our lives to look and then
is the
act are the actions that we're taking
congruent with how we want our life to
look
and so buying a car you can't afford
on payments is not going to give you the
life that you desire
so what steps what things are do i avoid
and what things do i do
that gives me the life that i want
that's a vision does that make sense
and so you know let me let me kind of
paint it out in other words you say okay
we're 30 uh and 25 when you're
40 i want to be an everyday
baby steps millionaire i want to have x
number of dollars in my 401k
i want to be able to go on some nice
trips
i want to be able to buy uh pay for
dinner at a nice restaurant
uh and i want to have an emergency fund
in place and i don't want to have any
debt
if you lay those things out and say
that's my 10-year goal
then when you get ready to do something
you say is this adding to the goal or
taking away from the goal
right but if you just wander around in
our society you will end up
buying crap you can't afford with money
you don't have
to impress people you don't really like
if you don't have a plan
right right and again it's more of an
emotional thing because again you know
what
both of our parents are doing very well
and we see the fruits of that
but again you know we just we just feel
sort of this urge to get there a little
bit quicker than we know it's going to
take
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good yeah and
you've mentioned the word emotional
twice
and and so what dave's trying to help
you see is big picture see your mom and
dad
struggled mightily you said yourself
when you grew up
they had nothing and you asked about
motivation what dave just laid out for
you david i want to make sure you caught
what he said
okay you got to have a vision for a
future and that'll take care of the
motivation so he was
he was describing your where and your
why where do you want to end up
why do you want to end up there that's
what he's laying out for you
when you get clear on that then the
motivation to sacrifice
to withhold what do you make is there
how much do you make
uh combined we make about 140 000. okay
goodness yeah okay so if you had an
emergency fund
and you had no debt and you were buying
your home you don't know 15-year fix and
you were paying it off
and you were saving towards retirement
and you wanted to spend 250
to go out to eat one night you could do
that easily in a really nice nice
restaurant couldn't you
yes sir okay so i'm not prescribing that
you have no life
i'm prescribing you have a life of
intentionality
not impulse and so if you
act like a child you're going to act
like most people
and operate on impulse but sharon and i
do
all kinds of really nice things david
and it's not because i make a lot of
money although i do
it's because i make a lot of money and
every one of those dollars has a
freaking assignment
sometimes the assignment is generosity
sometimes the assignment is dave wants
to
have some fun or sharon wants to have
some fun sometimes the assignment is
uh future investing uh and but
every you know it's all just on a plan
and uh
you know you can have a wonderful life
meanwhile building a wonderful life
yeah but again dave the key word you
just said there was plan
you got a plan that informs the name on
every dollar
and people want to know oh i can't get
motivated i can't get motivated well let
me tell you something
you're not motivated because you don't
have a very clear goal a clear direction
motive motive motive is the root word
there you gotta really lock in on that
so what's that desired future
when you both get really clear on that
then we can go oh okay
i know i really want a new mercedes but
that's not going to get me where i want
to go
and so you're motivated to sacrifice
you're motivated to be when i get there
i'll buy a new mercedes yes but that's
right
there is the key point yeah i mean but
right now i don't need to even be on the
website
because it just disturbs my brain that's
another good point dave if i stare at
you know website you don't need to go to
bars right
but i don't need to be looking at 5
million homes all day long
because if i do i'll start to develop an
appetite for that but i
can't do it not not today so that next
book you might there you go
you know but that's a really good point
so hey rachel's new book know yourself
know your money
talks about talks about your family that
you grew up in and how it affects these
decisions and you kind of mentioned that
a little bit
i'm going to send you a copy of that and
we have a fabulous
know yourself money assessment for
couples
and you guys i'm going to give you one
of those as well i'm going to sign you
up for that
and uh you guys take that as part of
your pre-marriage counseling it'll print
out this
fabulous thing showing everything your
fiance
thinks about money the way they're going
at this and the way you're going at it
and i think it'll add a lot of value to
this discussion for you
because i think what's happening is is
that
about the time one of you uh is being
wise and mature the other one's not
and then you swap places and uh you
gotta both get on the plan and just go
look
wisdom and maturity does not mean no fun
yeah it means higher quality fun it's a
really good point
i'm wondering dave if this sweet young
couple they watch their parents struggle
and sacrifice and now they're good
but he said something in the
conversation he said we want to get
there
faster i wonder if there's a little bit
of fear that oh i don't want to live it
out as long as my mama did we want to
get there we want to do better than mom
and dad i wonder if that's driving some
of this yeah
you see that with young people with this
you blink you're there
isn't that the truth you blink you're
there it's not it's
you're going to have plenty and you know
and
all along yeah at different stages with
different incomes and different net
worths
and different levels of investing and
different levels of generosity sharon
and i have had
the ability to enjoy money all along
yeah
but you don't you know if you're making
fifty thousand dollars he's making 140
000
you don't go buy a uh a 12 million
dollar house
you know and so there's no sense on
being on the website there's no sense
watching the tv shows about 12 million
dollar housing
isn't doing good no it doesn't doing
good it's it's counterproductive to what
your goal is
now you may be in a place someday that
you have a house like that
but not right now yeah this is the
ramsey show